les choses sont ainsi faites la
préparation de ce plat délicat qui
occupe dans l'anthologie culinaire
moderne la place comparable à celle de
bossuet dans la littérature la
préparation du homard grillé commence
par une saint barth ennemi selon la
terminologie consacrée le homard demande
à être découpé vivant et les runs en
coiffés en jupon qui procède à ce
massacre n'est autre que la paisible
denise de l'auberge de port royal à
saint lambert des bois le homard étant
donc découpé vivant par le milieu dans
le sens de la longueur la poche de sable
plate c'est près de la tête est enlevée
les pins sont cassés soigneusement un
supplice post mortem deux larrons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le corail et les oeufs sont
soigneusement enlevé et mis de côté ils
serviront dans un instant
et les deux moitiés du homard sont
disposés sur un plat en terre très
important c'est de moitié dans le plat
en terre sont saler et poivrer
légèrement puis lubrifié par
l'adjonction de quelques morceaux de
beurre et le plat est mis au four chaud
et pour 20 minutes exactement va me
pendant la cuisson écrasé un nike on va
mélanger avec du persil finement haché
et quelques échalotes également piler le
tout étant intimement brasser dans un
autre plaque
[Musique]
on ajoute maintenant les oeufs et le
corail à ce complexe à y percer
échalotes les cinq denrées étant encore
une fois énergiquement mélangé avec du
beurre frais enfin saler et poivrer avec
une pincée de cayenne
[Musique]
les 20 minutes sont écoulées la chair
des deux demi homard est maintenant à
point denise va donc garnir ses deux
demi homard avec la mixture que nous
venons de préparer avec elle le mélange
est en soigneusement napper jusqu'au
grade la carapace
[Musique]
et le tout est remise au four pour sept
ou huit minutes
ce homard grillé il convient en le
servant de le flamber au cognac
il est recommandé de l'escorté d'un
muscadet sèvre et maine 1957
[Musique]